Developer doesn't just mean encoding.
It's about finding out and creating new things.
You must put something of yourself,
make it personal, and I think it's an art form.
I'm Vincento Colucci; I am twenty-five years old;
and I am a developer here in Manfredonia, Italy.
Being a developer gives you the same power
as an inventor, and my dad always taught me
If you need something, you can build it.
That's what I'm trying to do as a developer, but with other tools.
For the first time I realized that developing for Android can be a real job
when I made my first program, Scratch Card.
A few days later I looked at my AdMob console and saw my first five dollars.
It was incredible. It felt like I would be rich!
With the money I made, I could pay for my studies
And that was a great goal for me.
Then I created Smart Launcher which was a new UI for Android devices.
It has a lot of cleanliness
home screen to draw your attention to the
main features of your phone. And the other programs
is automatically ranked in categories.
Android is the only platform that could work for me, because
Android is the only platform you can really do just what you want.
I can work in another city; I can work on a cruise ship,
but I decided to stay here in manfredonia, because here
do I have my friends;
I have my family; I have my girlfriend. I can work here - me
just need a laptop and internet connection.
When I published, my brother Daniele said
It's going to be your biggest failure. It's funny because if you are the one now
see figure,
I think no one will say it. I have more than that now
15 million downloads for the free version
and 200,000 for the professional version.
My program is downloaded all over the world. It's really popular.
It's very popular in India, America, and Japan.
I think Smart Launcher is actually the biggest export product of Manfredonia
To grow further is not something I expected.
I work closely with other people and it is very exciting, because now I can think of other products.
I think the future will be very exciting.
For me, success means doing what you want with your life.
To me it is to live in my city with my parents,
with my girlfriend, and to be happy.
And I can do this by being a developer.